the Joe Rogan experience when you were
growing up who what was the the fighter
that influenced you the most well
hands-down Floyd Mayweather and Roy
Jones jr. you know I used to love
watching Roy Jones jr. I'm pretty sure
everybody everybody was a fan of Roy but
set aside Roy always watched it Floyd
Mayweather and Pernell Whitaker yeah I
was too young for Sugar Ray Leonard and
them so I'm old enough for that I was
there for the Sugar Ray Leonard days I
was there for Sugar Ray Tommy Hearns
that the Sugar Ray duran I was there for
all that stuff but I watched everything
when I was when I was young my coach
Mitch miner he used to always take me to
his house and watch boxing tapes that
was the keep me off off the streets and
keep me out of trouble until I went to
the gym is he still around my pass
damn he probably look look at that what
did that work out you know we talked
about an investment in time that worked
out tremendously yeah it's always in our
culture there's a special place for the
highest level of boxers it was like a
special place of admiration and I just
feel like with guys like lomachenko with
guys like you with Canelo and triple G
this is a great time for boxing it's fun
to watch man there's so many Italy arrow
Spence jr. there's so many elite boxers
right now it's like a really exciting
time for sure for sure
do you recognize your place in history
to recognize that like you're a special
dude of course of course like I always
tell people when they mention me and
arrow Spence you know of course I want
the fight I tell everybody I always say
with or without him I'm going to the
Hall of Fame when you look at all the
things that I've accomplished in the
sport of boxing people that's in the
Hall of Fame didn't even Amish that you
know so I was I just tell people I don't
need them you really need me well we
need it right don't you agree you're
boxing do you need that stop boxing
needs it I mean it's one of the
beautiful things about when a canal and
a triple G do get together as you see
these guys in their respective weight
classes that are in their prime
it's fun you know like that's what
everybody wants to see that's the fact
that's what it's all about you just
stopped a whole lot of barbershop
conversation yes I need to stop a whole
lot of comedy club conversations barber
shop garage everywhere yeah that's the
that's the fight to make in your weight
class right now right for sure what's
whole what's the holdup
you got to axe down oh it's them
everybody has to hold out a little bit
right to get the best deal that's right
you know it's it's all about business
but at the same time my side of the deal
is ready whenever you can see all the
interviews out there man you can see
where if there's tears for myself or Bob
or anybody that's affiliated with Team
Crawford we all say we want to fight you
know yeah we had a fight tomorrow you
know if we wanted to so well we know is
literally see it won't happen
so when would you think that he's
waiting for the right time marketing
wise or do you think he's ready for the
right time where his skills he feels
like are able to challenge you like what
do you think is the actual holdup
I think it has something to do with Ty
Rankin PBC oh okay so it's a promoter
issue so it's a financial scramble I
won't say financial because the money
will be there if the fight was ever made
I just think it's you know Eagles yeah I
think egos price of Eagle so do you
think hopefully this is just something
it's gonna take a little while but it
will eventually come to play
of course I think yeah it happened you
know but I think you know me being with
top-ranked and stand in the way of a lot
of things happening mmm that makes sense
that makes sense it's like it's
interesting that promoters of boxing
promoters work together well at all
right you know like you think about it
like if the UFC how to work with
Bellator and put together some world
championship fight every basically
there's so many times you get champion
versus champion they have two different
promoters and have to decide to get
together and make this happen who want
to get the most of the pot that's yes or
what never is gonna be yeah
phox or ESPN and who's gonna promote it
and it's also like when someone like
Floyd Mayweather has done what he's done
and sold the kind of paper views that
he's sold and then you know and achieved
this sort of level of financial Fame as
well as like people he's famous not just
for being the best boxer but famous for
being insanely rich like that's part of
the fame because he promoted yes he
promoted because he figured it out and a
lot of other people are gonna probably
try to do the same thing as well right
that's not my style
[Applause]